[Music]
oh it is the day for so many fans of
Star Wars you know it before I even say
it may the fourth be with you oh man
today is the national Star Wars day of
course and is May for those of you who
don't know May the 4th that is quite
literally the day that it is you're
getting faster at it I'm getting it it
runs right off your tongue now if I say
it enough and maybe I'll Waltz myself
into a theater and watch one of those
movies you sound like a Star Wars
natural do you know who Chewbacca is oh
yeah I think he's the big brown thing
the big hairy guy yeah so did you know
the Darth Vader's sister is in high-rise
buildings all around the world
what yeah her name is Ella Ella elevator
Vader
[Laughter]
meanwhile it is that was a showstopper I
have not been there